¿Cuáles creéis que son mejores, los países
grandes o los países pequeños? ¿Cuáles
pensáis que tienen más éxito? Parecen preguntas
tontas, pero, amigos, os garantizo que no lo son.
Vivimos en un mundo donde cada vez hay más
países, así que, evidentemente, cada vez
hay más países pequeños.
Desde 1950 nuestro mundo ha pasado de tener,
unos 60 países a casi 200 hoy en día..
Así que,amigos, creo que esto nos obliga
a plantearnos unas cuantas preguntas
¿Esto es algo bueno, o es algo malo? ¿Son los países
pequeños viables? Vamos a verlo en este vídeo,
pero antes un apunte.
Cuando hablemos de países pequeños nos vamos
a referir a países con una población de
menos de 10 millones de habitantes; y también
incluiremos a Hong Kong y Macao, porque aunque
formalmente sean parte de China, bueno, tienen
sus propias leyes, sus propios tribunales,
sus propias aduanas, etcetera etcetera.
"Hong Kong tiene su propia moneda, su propia política de inmigración y también
policía, aduanas y tribunales propios. Vamos, que en el día a día funciona casi como un país independiente.
Pero dicho esto… vayamos a la cuestión
clave, a que está pasando con los países pequeños.
Y, ojo, porque este es un tema muy importante
en la política internacional.
Todos lo sabemos, una buena parte de los conflictos
políticos tienen mucho que ver precisamente
con esto… con el deseo de muchos territorios
de declararse independientes y constituirse
en nuevos países.
LA FUERZA DE LOS PEQUEÑOS
Amigos, no cabe duda, los países pequeños
no suelen estar entre los grandes protagonistas
de la actualidad internacional:
no se les tiene muy en cuenta en los grandes
conflictos, no participan en las grandes decisiones
y, la verdad, su actualidad política suele
ser una gran desconocida.
Y al fin y al cabo es algo normal... Todos
conocemos al Presidente de Estados Unidos,
al de Francia o al de Rusia, pero ¿A quién
le importa quien mande en países como Irlanda,
Dinamarca o Taiwan?
[Sí, es verdad, en VisualPolitik solemos
hablar de ellos, pero, realmente no es algo
tan frecuente]
Pero, amigos, esperad un momento porque a
pesar de todo esto, lo cierto es que en los
últimos 30 años si algo ha caracterizado
a los países pequeños ha sido hacer las
cosas bastante, pero que bastante mejor que
lo países grandes.
De hecho, cada vez que se publica un ranking
sobre cuales son los países más ricos, o
los más innovadores, o lo más competitivos,
los más felices o los más seguros… los
países pequeños ocupan casi siempre la mayoría
de las primeras posiciones.
Y sí, entonces es cuando nos damos cuenta
de que existen y nos preguntamos,
¿cómo diantres lo hacen?
Fijaos, si cogemos, por ejemplo, el ranking
de los países más ricos del mundo, esto es, de los
países con un PIB per cápita mayor, nos
encontramos com que entre los 10 países más
ricos del mundo, 9, repito, 9 son países pequeños.
Y, por cierto, de estos 9 países , ni más ni menos que 8 tienen menos de 6 millones de habitantes, es decir,
que son bastante más pequeños que Bogotá
o incluso que el área metropolitana de Madrid.
Pero bien, si en vez de tomar los 10 primeros,
venga ampliamos un poquito la selección y
escogemos los 25 primeros, pues en ese caso
vemos como la cosa cambia algo… pero...
no mucho.
De los 25 países más ricos del mundo, atentos,  17
son países pequeños.
(Y si, además, tenemos en cuenta la diferencia
de precios, esto es si tomamos el PIB per cápita
en paridad de poder de compra… entonces
ya los datos son de escándalo:
En ese caso, los 14 territorios más ricos
del mundo son todos países pequeños)
Y, ojo, amigos, porque hablamos de países
muy diferentes:
Algunos tienen mucha densidad de población
como Singapur, otros muy poca, como Finlandia.
Algunos tienen muchos recursos naturales, como Qatar, y otros prácticamente ninguno, como Irlanda
hay países más agrícolas… y
otros más financieros; grandes en territorio
y otros muy pequeñitos.
Es decir, que la variedad es enorme… pero
todos tienen una característica común:
son estados formados por pocos habitantes.
Hablamos de países como Islandia, Nueva Zelanda,
Luxemburgo, Noruega, Irlanda, Dinamarca, Singapur,
Austria, Suiza o Finlandia, por ejemplo.
Pues bien, precisamente, en 2014 y en 2015,
dos estudios publicados por la unidad de investigación
de Credit Suisse corroboraron está situación:
(Estos estudios encontraron que los países
pequeños tienden a ser más ricos, más igualitarios
y más avanzados socialmente. De hecho, de
media invierten bastante más en cosas como
la educación o la sanidad.
Y eso no es todo, por si no fuese suficiente,
los países pequeños suelen tener las cuentas
más ordenadas, tienen menos deuda, menos
déficit y, también, menos impuestos, a pesar
de lograr mejores resultados sociales.)
Bueno, es que, incluso si nos fijamos en sus
mercados financieros, en las bolsas, por ejemplo,
vemos como en las últimas décadas los mercados
de los países pequeños han tenido mejores resultados.
Atentos:
Así que, amigos, insisto con una pregunta,
que estoy convencido muchos os estáis haciendo
¿Qué está pasando? ¿Cómo diantres lo
hacen? Bien, veámoslo.
LAS CLAVES DEL ÉXITO
¿Por qué los países pequeños tienden a
funcionar mejor que los más grandes?
¿No se supone que los países grandes tienen mercados
más grandes, más oportunidades de negocios
y encima más capacidad para aprovechar economías
de escala? ¿Qué está fallando?
Y no, lo siento, el cliché de los paraísos
fiscales… no vale. Ni Finlandia, ni Austria,
ni Dinamarca, ni por supuesto Nueva Zelanda, por ejemplo,
pueden ser considerados, bajo ningún concepto,
paraísos fiscales.
Entonces, ¿Cual es la explicación?
Bien, como solemos decir, aquí en VisualPolitik,
nunca suele existir una única causa, pero
sí podemos decir que la prosperidad de estos
países procede en gran medida de su propia debilidad.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
(Estos países pequeños están más expuestos
al comercio internacional, no solo para vender
sino también, muy importante, para comprar
los productos que necesitan. Es evidente que
un país pequeño no puede producir de todo.
Y luego, también, están más expuestos a
la competencia y a los vaivenes de los mercados
financieros internacionales.)
Así que… amigos, esto les obliga a ser
más prudentes con las cuentas, a cuidar su
competitividad y, por supuesto,no pueden permitirse
el lujo de aplicar políticas proteccionistas.
De hecho, 21 de los 25 países más globalizados,
esto es que más abiertos están a la circulación
de mercancías, personas y capitales, son
países pequeños.
Por su parte, si queremos ver como estos países
se preocupan por la competitividad de su economía
y de sus empresas, tan solo tenemos que echar
un vistazo, por ejemplo, al índice Doing
Business del Banco Mundial, que como sabéis
clasifica a los países por su facilidad para
hacer negocios.
Pues bien, atentos al último Doing Business
2018, que el Banco Mundial publicó el
31 de octubre de 2017.
(El ranking Doing Business del Banco Mundial
también está dominado por los países pequeños.
Nueva Zelanda, Singapur, Dinamarca y Hong
Kong ocupan 4 de las 5 primeras plazas.
Entre los 25 países del mundo donde más
fácil resulta hacer negocios, 16 son países
pequeños. De estos 16, 15 tienen menos menos
habitantes que el área metropolitana de Madrid.)
Y aún existe otro motivo de peso más.
Veréis, los países pequeños, suelen tener
mucha menos burocracia:
primero porque no necesitan tantas estructuras
políticas o al menos es más difícil justificarlas;
segundo porque los ciudadanos suelen ser más
conscientes del coste que suponen; y tercero
porque simplemente no se lo puede permitir.
El resultado de todo ello, amigos, es que
los países pequeños suelen ser más flexibles,
más competitivos y menos burocráticos.
Claro que puede que alguno de vosotros esté
pensado, pero Enrique ¿No será que estos
pequeños países son más ricos porque se
han creado sobre las zonas, los territorios,
más ricos?
Pues lo cierto es que no.
Tenemos el caso de Irlanda o Singapur, por
ejemplo, que hace apenas unas décadas eran
países bastante pobres y hoy son dos de los
países más ricos del mundo.
Y también tenemos otro buen ejemplo en la
antigua república checoslovaca.
LA PRUEBA DE LA SEPARACIÓN
Sí, nos vamos a tierras de Fonseca, que seguramente
dentro de no mucho nos cuente esta historia
con todo lujo de detalles, pero hoy tan solo
un par de apuntes:
Mirad, en 1993 Checoslovaquia decidió dividirse
en dos países más pequeños,
la República Checa y Eslovaquia.
(Por aquel entonces los dos países estaban
sufriendo los efectos de la caída de la Unión
Soviética, y estaban experimentando una dura
transición, pero la parte checa era mucho
más rica que la parte eslovaca.
De hecho, en Eslovaquia la renta per cápita
era apenas un 65% de la checa, la tasa de
desempleo era casi 5 veces más alta y encima
la región eslovaca era muy dependiente del
dinero que llegaba en forma de “solidaridad
interregional” desde la parte más rica
del país, o sea de Chequia.)
Pues bien, desde que separaron en 1993, a
los dos países no les ha ido nada mal:
Consiguieron realizar con éxito la transición
desde un modelo comunista a un modelo capitalista
y los dos han crecido bastante más, por ejemplo,
que Alemania.
Ahora bien, de los dos países, el que más
progresos ha logrado ha sido precisamente
Eslovaquia.
Sí, así es. Poder organizarse por sí mismo
y al mismo tiempo tener que competir, favoreció
sobre todo a la parte más pobre.
Fijaos, como desde entonces se ha producido
una clara convergencia entre los dos países.
Atentos al gráfico.
Pero de todo esto, con todo lujo de detalles,
estoy seguro que ya nos hablará Fonseca.
Pero, amigos, por mi parte, un último apunte,
antes de terminar.
LA NUEVA CONFIGURACIÓN DEL MUNDO
Seamos claros, la globalización ha hecho que ser un país grande ya no sea una ventaja.
Y no solo eso.
Lo cierto es que en el mundo que estamos construyendo aspectos como la competitividad,
la apertura y la capacidad de adaptación son cada vez
más importantes.
Y de momento, amigos, ese ámbito los países
pequeños parecen más eficientes.
Los países pequeños… e incluso, las ciudades.
Sí, habéis escuchado bien. En nuestro mundo,
las grandes ciudades se han convertido en
los motores más importes del crecimiento
económico…
(Londres y su City, Hong Kong, Singapur, Macao…
las ciudades cada vez juegan un papel más
importante en nuestro mundo.
La economía de Yakarta crece el doble que
la economía de Indonesia, el PIB de Nueva York
es dos veces el de Suecia y los países
con más porcentaje de población viviendo
en las ciudades tienden a ser más ricos.)
Así que, me hago una pregunta: a tenor de
los datos ¿No deberíamos apostar por estados
más pequeños, descentralizados o, incluso,
por dar cierta independencia a las ciudades?
Ahí lo dejo.
Por supuesto, nada de esto reñido, con desarrollar
organizaciones supranacionales para hacer
frente a muchos de los riesgos a los que nos
enfrentamos: desde el terrorismo hasta el
cuidado del medio ambiente.
Pero ahora, turno para ti: ¿Qué crees que
es mejor, un mundo con muchos y pequeños países
que colaboren y compitan entre si;
o un mundo con pocos y grandes países?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y,
también, en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si aun no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.